Chris Columbus's 1993 comedy Miss
downfire easily ranks among Robin
williams' best ever films the movie
follows Williams is Daniel Hillard who
goes through a complicated divorce with
his wife Miranda and finds himself
unable to see his children as often as
he would like to combat this Daniel
takes on the Persona of an elderly woman
known as Mrs downfire who acts as a
housekeeper and Nanny giving the father
more time to see his kids as well as
being incredibly funny the film expertly
deals with issues around family
separation and abandonment by the end
Daniel and Miranda come to find a new
respect for each other and put in place
a plan for joint custody putting forward
the idea that the children should come
first but this message was almost eroded
in the original script as it concluded
with the separated couple getting back
together to make one big happy family
Williams and director Chris Columbus
pushed back believing that this ending
was neither realistic nor helpful to
younger viewers who might watch it and
therefore expect their own parents to
get backed together they eventually won
the argument with the filmmakers and
Studio executives relenting